ok story da diese video gerade hoch am
freitag dem irgendwann kriegt im februar
das heißt gestern war als beirat mit dem
karnevalsbeginn mehr oder weniger von
diesem tier pro tag und ihr mit
halbwissen in köln wir wirklich immer
karneval zelebrieren
wir haben also gestern morgen gegen halb
in meinem kollegen im rheinauhafen
getroffen haben wir ihn halt vor nicht
vorgedrungen
und ich habe mich schon die ganze zeit
gedacht ok jeden fall auch dein handy
auch noch keine wertgegenstände auch als
schlüssel portemonnaie ist er in einem
karneval kann es schon sein dass man
einiges verlieren bzw
doch einiges kaputt geht dann machen wir
auf jeden fall moritz also moritz ist
dieser typ ford sync machen aber auch
alles ganz cool wir haben junge spieler
für elf vegas party maß aller dinge
irgendwann dann und ich war wirklich
überhaupt nicht betrunken ich habe
wirklich nicht viel vor getrunken um
erfolg zu kommen
ich weiß man nie aber mein handy
komplett mutter wirklich sagen hey
funktioniert nur wenn ich jetzt hier
anpacken wollte ich kann das auch noch
ganz normal alles für dich benutzen und
so arbeitet komplett finden keine aus
dem display eines gesprungen als es mir
auf dem boden gefallen lg staufen boten
der fall werde natürlich glauben kammer
hat war einfach so gegenteil ich
unterwegs via garstige wetter beim ohren
vorträgen und es gibt ein paar regeln
wenn man sich vor dringend machen oder
sich mal ein automat oder eben die tore
machen ist dass man nie der gastgeber
sein sollte wenn man allerdings die
gastgeber beim teuren dann greift regel
nummer drei und regel nummer drei hat
man den gierigen nummer eins noch mal
anschauen seien nie der gastgeber moritz
war der gastgeber und der krieg war
moritz wohnung aufkommen
also der ganze boden da kassen voll mit
mir über alles und wir brauchen wir
spieler weiten ball von tirol überall
mit 20 30 freunden aber ich und ich als
netter sozialer mensch und freund moritz
hat wieder einmal den staubsauger von
open als er kennt halt oben und unten
ist halt so da die partie war hab ich
den stoff geholt und hat uns im staub
genau hat dem staubsauger wieder nach
oben gebracht
rückfällig wird interaktionen bestimmt
jetzt nur einen kopf bestimmt irgendwas
positive heute antrag zurück als ich
dann den staubsauger nach oben gebracht
hat und wieder nach unten gegangen wenn
nachts nicht mehr halt nicht eingegangen
die rot grün drauf geguckt dann habe ich
wieder in die tasche weg und ich habe
die taschen nicht getroffen und voll auf
den boden geklappt hätten in diesem
moment euer handy einfach so auf den
boden fällt nicht gut genug ist kaputt
und seitdem war ein ganzer tag hart weil
in diesen momenten penny runter gefallen
und hatte ich mich schon so gedacht und
jetzt april hat mich diese kleider oder
krankheit einfach gut 400 euro gekostet
und ja apple scheiben kosten der fed 400
euro für das liebenswerte aus der größte
verfahren damit dass hier geld zu kommen
da kann ich mir fast neue reifen kaufen
digger ist mir auch egal auf jeden fall
will ich auch gar nicht beschweren und
der sieht ja nicht heute wieder meine
familie mein fehler und ich meine wenn
ich wenig betroffen gewesen wäre darüber
dass strafe dafür dass die fische oder
wochen aber nicht
ich war einfach nüchtern aber wie gesagt
ist mir auch egal ich wollte euch nur
deswegen sagen warum wahrscheinlich
erstmal nicht so viele snacks apple
werden und in pretoria mit der
frontkamera die hat auch gespielt hatte
und ich wollte heute eigentlich von mods
und mai vorn video machen wenn sie das
häufiger gewünscht hat und danach auch
schon mal gefragt haben wir jetzt eine
darüber öffentlich von dauer
leute die mit leitet der ablauf man
leichter und weil 50.000 leicht auf
jeden fall 50.000 leicht die mir nicht
bringen übrigens feiert das wartet ihr
vom video meine damen und herren ich
hoffe es hat euch vielleicht wenige fall
weiteres tor wollte einfach nicht
einfach gerne fehlen mein handy kaputt
gegangen hätte auch einem einer story so
drin hatte von wegen handy am ohr hier
könne dabei die eingeblendeten er darauf
legen könnt ihr ein fanal kostenlos
abonnieren verpasste keine videos mehr
zu machen kunden hier ist ein anderes
video direkt auf einer treppe damit man
die nicht sehen muss kein problem
das weiter